George people said George Clooney's at  the time a mall George Clooney's getting  married yeah yeah come on  come on firm Bachelor but you met Amal  Clooney and what happened to you George  I was no longer confirmed it was easy it  was the minute she walked in the door I  was just you know taken by her and uh  and the fun part was you know we didn't  I didn't know whether you know she would  like me or any of those things and then  uh wait George stop it and then we would  know if them all would like you yes and  you know and and then you know she's  this  extraordinarily you know fun smart  beautiful great woman and you know it  was I was just very taken with that